ecole valentin pour ainsi dire comme un
lundi matin dans la zone commerciale les
enseignes sont ouvertes dans la galerie
marchande de l'hypermarché
ça tient plus du jour férié sur ces
images amateurs on constate qu hormis la
grande surface
seules les boutiques dites essentielles
comme la boulangerie et la pharmacie
sont ouvertes
parmi les professionnels obligé de
rester rideau baissé
cette gérante de boutiques de
prêt-à-porter on a reçu un mail samedi
soir de la part de notre bailleur à 21h
nous informant que le centre commercial
fermerait ses portes à minuit
donc on a été tous sous le choc tous
abasourdis puisque le samedi la journée
s'était très bien passée ensemble
commercial les jo j'étais tout respecté
et et pour nous on ne faisait pas partie
des centres commerciaux à près de 20
mille mètres carrés pour la troisième
fois en onze mois
les boutiques de la galerie sont donc à
l'arrêt les clients rencontrés ce lundi
matin ne cachaient pas leur
incompréhension
tous les magasins ils devraient rester
ouverts avec les précautions cette eau
fallait fermer avant ce grand centre
parce qu'on les a laissés pendant noël
on les a laissé tout le temps donc
et un peu d'illogisme là dedans on va
dans un hangar four et qui ont peut pas
aller dans la galerie en fait on se
marche sur la tête une fois plus ce qui
pose question c'est que plus d'une
dizaine d'emplacements de boutiques sont
inoccupés des cellules de 60 à 120
mètres carrés placés en location
comptabilisé pourtant dans le décret du
ministère de la santé
ce que ne comprend pas cette gérante
d'un salon de coiffure j'aimerais me
battre pour que les six mètres carrés
qui ne sont pas exploitées qui
n'accueille pas de public comme nous
réservent les toilettes les laboratoires
ne soit pas dans le comptage et du coup
nous permettent de rester au vert en
attendant un confinement général seul
espoir pour les commerces dits non
essentiels de la galerie marchande que
la préfecture reviennent sur cette
situation paradoxale